كعادتها منذ اشهر تصل تتيانا الى مجارها
فيكرامكس
المهندسه التي اضطرت مثل الالاف من من
خسروا اعمالهم نتيجه الحرب الى تغيير
مهنتها
تصف قرارها افتتاح المتجر بالعفوي
والاضطراري بعد ان اغلقت بوجهها كل السبل
لكن كل شيء توقف منذ اليوم الاول للحرب
نبع حافظه المياه الساخنه وادوات للصيد
وبعض الالعاب انا ممتنه لانني لم ابقى
عاطله عن العمل
بشده العوده الى العمل
وفقد الالاف ومصادرهم
سكان المدينه
لكن اخرين غيروا مختارين مهنهم بعد ان
اوجدت الحرب لهم مصدر رزق جديده
الحديثه هنا عن محل بيع المستلزمات الجنود
التي باتت مهنه رائجه خاصه في المدن
القريبه من منطقه العمليات
صوفيا واحده من هؤلاء وجدت في هذه التجاره
النسائيه ومستحضرات التجميل لكنني قررت ان
اغير البضاعه الى ما تراه كانت صعوبه
بدايه في ايجاد الموردين خصوصا مع التوقف
المصانع هنا عن العمل وجدتما ابحث عنه في
تركيا وتصلني البضائع باسعار تنافسيه
عشان يرجعوا ومن لم يتمكن حتى من استئجار
متجر صغير وجد في بسط بضاعته على قارعه
الطريق حلا لتسب قوته
ليس الامر سهلا على هؤلاء الباعه الجوال
خاصه في هذه الظروف الجويه القاسيه
ولكنه وقوف هؤلاء في الاسواق قد يصادف
مرور متطوعين من فرق غنائيه تتنقل بين
المدن القريبه من مناطق القتال بهدف ادخال
السعاده على قلوب المدنيين من من اثروا
البقاء في هذه المدن
لم يستسلم هؤلاء للعجز وقله الامكانات فمن
نحن الى اخرى تكيف كثير منهم مع ظروف
الحرب الصعبه عاملين بالمثل الاوكراني
القائل حيثما توجد حياه يوجد امل عمر
الحاجه جزيره كرامته